N ANOTHEE OCUMENBRK AT
CO IN JULY
2021 INDICATING THATD A TA
YIMMENTS WIN RESPONSLLEY, WAS
TO AYORK"
T
YOU'RE GOIing WAR.
OREN
N
N SPOK
EXCLUSIVELY WITHER WTO Y IST
IN
FORMER PRESID
YOU WEREAN
AND
D O R ME TO COMMT  THAT ONGOINL
IN INAPPROPRIATE.
THERE'S AN ONGOING FEDERAL
VEND I'M NOT GOING
TO COMMENT ONE WAY OR ANOTHER ON
Y AT. GET MORE INSIGHT
TONIGHT FROMUMP
AL SECURY ADVISER JOHNBOLTON.
THANK YOU,NG
YOU HEARD FROM GENERALLE
WEIGHING IROM OUR RERT
THS SPOKEN TO
INST.
EN IMES TO THIS
DOMEP ALLEGEDLY
RI IOW
DOCUMENT TRUMP COULD HAVE BEEN
LD HANDSG?
>> I DON'T THINKHE
ANY WAY OF KNOWING.
AND GIVEP'S PROPENSITY TO
OVERSTATE THINGS, IT'S ENTIRELY
HANDS SOMETHINKE THE LUNCH FM ER
THAT HE WAS
.HAT MARK MILLEY MIGE
FUNDAMENTAL POINT.VE ANYRE
INVOLVED HERE.
BUYOU ACTUALLY
I THINK IT'STANT NOT TO F OVERH
PROPENSITY TO TICLY WITH
BLUSTER -- TA
FOR THAT I WON'T USET HIS PROPET
>> THERE'S CONCERN FROM PR THEY
CLEARLY WANT TORT IS.
THEY BROUGHT
JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF TO TALK
ABOUT IT.UAH DOCUMENT TRUMP WASG
AT THAT TIME, IF HWA
SENT A SUBPOENA, THE CLEAR, I WT
WAS TALKING ABOU TAPE.
TRUMP'NOT
CATE THET
IT.
SO, IF HWALDIN
DOCUMENT AND THEY WERE
>> WELL, IF IT WERE ANL CONCER?
T TH
PREDA PLAN, THAT
IF IT'S SIMPLY TRUMP MAKING IT
UP AG,UL
EXPLAIN  CAN'T FIND  NEVER.
I MEANTHR EXPLANATION IS DESTRES
WOULD SHOW, ARY INTENT
THAT HE D A HIGHLY CLAIFIED .
THE IDEAHAU CAN TAKE
GH, THE REAL OFFICL
DOCUMENTE PENTAGONORN
AND KIND OSPREAD THE,
E PRESIDENT, I WOULD
BE VERY SURPRISED  THEY ARE
DEABLY KEPT VERY T
HELD, INFREQUENTLYAKY
OM THE PENTAGON,ND
OR THE OVAOFH GR WHETHLE WHO BRT
THEM OR LEAVE.D A LEVEL OF CONC.
SUSPECTS IRANIAN OPERATIVE LASTT
FRONT OF WN ITTHEN
OBSERVATIONS
ABOUT TOWARDCHAIRMAN MILLEY?ELL
E DUNFORD, WHOAS THJO
THBE THE
ADMINISTRATION, WAS GOING ON
ANSO
THAT MK MILLEY SHOULD BE AIRMAN
STAFF.
WITH THAT AND APPOTE
AT THE BEGINNING, HE WAS THAT .
ANBE THAAT
THME
I WAK, WHEN A LOT  THIS RE
PEPPENED.T IT'SBV THAONSHIP BETT
>> AWE S THESE
VEUPAIT TO SEET THL DOES ON THI
DOCUIGATION,IS STILL THEFOICAN
PRESIDENT.
YOU'VE SAID YOU'RE CONSIDE AUNHD
>> NO, I HWAITH
SOF R NOT DO THI
THAT WOU I THINKANNSIVE JOB TO S
I THINK IT'SCAL FOR TH PARTY, A
WELL, THATOT
I TH RACT BIDE
GH WIN., I THINK THIS IS A SERI
GOING TO HAVE TO DEAWITH.
DOCUMENTS CASE TO SAVES ON
KNOWING TRUMP, HE MAY WELL T H T
DECISION  THE TH SEEING
HOW TH?
>> WELL,RAAT'S ANOTHER
PEOPLE WANDE AD SEEKK
THERE WOULD BE AAS
WOULD BE ADDIN
I THINRY
90 DAYS, IT'TW
TRUMP.N GOVERNOR DeSANTIAND
I THINK KNOWING TRUMP AS I
THAT HE WILL UNLOA DeSANTIS UNC
QUALIFIED TO BE PRESIDENT. REAL.
U' TT E
REPUBLICAN NOMINATION BYNTOING H
NOMINATION BN
TAKING TRUMP ON DIRECTLYHEY'RE
WE OF TH
-- TRUMP NINTH  I
NO OLDRE HIS NAME ON.
OU THINKT'STAKR
RNTO NOT
LY CRITICIZE TN THIS
RA
%.S NO ISSUE ABOUT
MP HAS
PHILOSOPHY.
AND IT'S NOT ISSUE S PERSONALIT
MPEN HIS COM BE
HAVE.DENT, WHICH HE DOES
AND I THINK UNLESS YOU M
POINT EFFECTIVELY  VOTANIGNORE P
E
THPERSON WHO
ULTIMATELY WINS THAN
NONAPERSON WHO AT
AND AS YOUAYD  I
ANYBODY HAS STEPPED
UP TO THAT ROLE.
MAYBE CHRIS CHRIS HIM IF HE DOE.
IF HE DOESN'T, SOMEBODY NEEDS
TE NOMINATION.E
>> WE'LL SEE WHAT U DECIDE
ULTIMATE
STENING TO THES WE WERE AB CNN
STIGATORS
LOOKING INTO A POOL THAT WAS
E  FDED A ROOM
KNOW PROSECUTORS HAVE
SUBPOENAED.
STILL T IONS ABOUT
THAT.
WHAT WAS YOUACING TH WRI BE SUS
TRANTYO
OBSTRUCT JUSTICE
THIS PR EPISODE,
ANS A LITTLELIKET NOT
BEYOND THE
IMPOSSIBLE.
I DON'T MEGRAPHY HEHIGH TO
UNDERSTAND HOW DRAINING THE POOL
WOIS ROOM.
T YOU'VE GOT TO PURSUE EVERY
N A CA